it's really incredible I don't know we I
feel like we've been wondering and
waiting about what tonight would be like
for so long that I'm so excited and I
just don't can't believe they're
actually people here yeah I mean it's I
feel pretty good being here I was the
guy I guess especially gray this is this
what's all about you know this is what
we did it for nights like this and get
to show it off and I see what those
caption is and yet that's insane but
it's pretty this is amazing I mean I'm
really excited to be in London and to
bring it home and yeah I feel really
good about it when I wrote this I never
ever envisaged doing this unless the
square I mean I do I can hardly believe
it it's just picturing myself everyone's
here it wasn't my imagination and it's
like whoa she's a young woman who
carries herself with grace and strength
and is an innocent person and then you
kind of watch her go through something
incredibly profound as a woman you see
her turn into a woman and explore her
emotions and her sexuality and and it's
a beautiful story and something unique
and different yeah i mean the code is
great i mean the first time I met her I
sort of knew that like we'd be like
mates you know she's right for me I
sometimes think I'm funny and we just
had this sort of rapport with each other
that was easy and then over time we
built up but you know trust for each
other you know and you need that many
actor actress even if you're doing a day
with them but given them a good time to
go to nice but together in the nature of
what we were doing
Trust was the most essential thing you
know and I thought that we had done
abundance I mean Dakota was incredible
and I met with her very early on in the
process and she came in and she just
embodied Anastasia still very quickly
and and then Jamie I met much later in
the process and and the thing is it's
very hard to cast someone who's written
as physically perfect charismatic stylet
you know all of those things and can act
and the amazing thing is Jamie had all
of those but the attribute that made me
want him which is a very soulful person
and and I hope that comes through I mean
I genuinely I would describe 56 degrees
being I do think honestly I love story
and people talk about the sex and look
sex is a massive part about it and it's
an erotic series of novels and it's an
aerobic film but it's still got a love
story you know you don't sell that many
books and keep people's interest over
three long books without there being it
can't just be free long books about S&M
sex you know it has to be a summer story
that's being something at the core and
that is a love story thats these two
people who you know on paper shouldn't
really be together and make massive
sacrifices to make it work and you know
we've seen that before and stories gone
by and I think that's what I think
fundamentally as a love story it's a
very complex love story and you go on
the full journey you know behind closed
doors everything and
and the most important thing for me was
the feeling that Anastasia isn't a
victim to it she's a very much empowered
woman by the end of it and and actually
it's Christian Grey that becomes the
vulnerable one I mean I think Christian
Grey is this very tortured fermented
broken unhappy man who really struggles
with contentment and he's been through
awful soft and his youth that has made
him that way and that has manifested
itself in high he approached his
business and high he bruises
relationships and always sort of
incapable of love and and it's quite
hard he's quite a heartbreaking
character the films I found myself
feeling sorry for Bella he's obviously
got all the wealth in the world and
everything but if you can't be happy
what something I nearly got the part
before and then someone else got it you
know so I could have done all my
thinking about about what it would mean
getting it and then suddenly you know
unforeseen circumstances I'm and I'm
back in it so I've got my head wounded
by that stage I was feeling good about
it it was pretty challenging but I'd say
actually the whole movie from beginning
to end was pretty challenging and I mean
the intimate scenes they were received
into the end of the movie because I
really wanted to build trust between
Dakota and I Jamie and I and the two
together so by the time we got there we
felt pretty well I would never say all
ready for that kind of thing but we felt
like we could accomplish what we needed
I was nervous I was terrified until last
Friday when we screen it in front of fan
screening in New York and everyone was
happy and I think my work here is done
yeah I was happy think that people will
be hopefully happy I think that they'll
get some of the stuff that they loved in
the book and hopefully they'll laugh a
little maybe cry a little